Oh gum with my name welcome back to Alan
Garcia today you will never guess skip
shut up
that's how I rock don't need another one
to get over there oh can I just jump I
thought I only saw one I place this one
yeah oh yeah draw what can I put it back
why did you do that
I'll come oh thank god alright do I
really need another one I copy you
[ __ ] bad you [ __ ] up my video what
are you doing trying to offer me cakes a
barrel cake does not work with me all
right
don't lean on my head god damn baby I -
Tony head [ __ ] girls dancing on my head
I got boxes I need another one of those
no [ __ ] I'm out of it aw come on
this game is so dark I don't I don't
know alright there you are door can
barely see you now doing alright let's
see I'm gonna go for the jump let's just
go for the jump rush nice guy - Narnia
Oh [ __ ] made it
what was the point of going there anyway
yeah [ __ ] trust there was no purpose
whatsoever wasn't it there was a clue
here I need a like a lever
as next to the library I remember that
[ __ ] don't think I don't you're locked
I'm battery Oh Tomas I grabbed you thank
you very much all right
hey I just met you and you're a lever
so let me drunk you what the [ __ ] dad
you're saying
No
no no no it's impossible oh [ __ ] my life
hi hey Jenna no it's so cozy as we read
a couple of books
what is this is this vampire Twilight
what are you doing hi I'm sorry I'm just
reading why are you ringing Twilight so
chest ah
I [ __ ] tinderboxes I don't need Tina
Baca
I need batteries Tina Rises like from
then 19 Sony's pick them yeah all right
we need to go where's the lever it's
probably down there god damn it why I
just find a lever all right go now
[ __ ] you barrel here ah I like slowly
some more cuz here right now I'm doing
enjoy le oh yeah
another door no way probably go through
this thing's door go then [ __ ] off
barrel and why is his open ah okay
there's a room here and someone peed
their pants in here it wasn't me I swear
and they're reading a book probably have
you thought their thumb [ __ ]
alright is this oh jeez I did it I
should head back to the archives chica
Robles secret room find the level
without even looking for that's how I
roll it you see that [ __ ] barrels you
see that [ __ ] you try to hide [ __ ] from
me that's how I alright now I can head
back
fine don't [ __ ] with me right now door
no thank you door
I just want to go home it's such a
[ __ ] hangover alright for lady gaga
wow it works every time when I see Lady
gaga she's one fine lady I tell you as
much alright so now I can go here No
what the [ __ ] what No
why did I pull that lever then why did I
fall in love or whatever we're doing
here press no ads that you maybe for us
a little [ __ ] lighter it said I
should head back that night why you know
open you [ __ ] all right fine
you know what going back to the our case
I'm doing it because I suck I really
[ __ ] pathos not good for my brain it
has negative effect of my brain brows
it's not good it's not it's not good
pull my brain why can't you see the
ramen that's why I like to go outside in
the rain and like to go and take a train
because can't see I can't even wrap any
mind not that I was
that's that noise did you move super
confused period super confused I just
kind of roll with it for now
are you the single route where's all
right done there's less he played I I
wish I was like screaming [ __ ] pain
tanks what do you want from me painting
paintings falling in my face man the
[ __ ] man
I mean like me why was that
he's been teasing me the sexual sounds
for so long that I don't know mad I
don't I don't know buddy
nice let's go here what
uh no ah
uh-uh no I must feel the dot I don't
have anything to seal the door well I
don't have come on that was push it to
the limit
miss jet do it I keep it all right all
right where do I go where do I go
whatever I want to go to do I don't even
[ __ ] see anything
you must seal the door the [ __ ] back oh
I get it
hideous barrels
seriously so died that's I can't deal
with this darkness A to Z it's pissing
me off right now game
hi thank thank you I just needed a
[ __ ] see where my camera all right
now we must feel the time where oh oh oh
don't you pass what ah [ __ ] my life
hey do you want this hey [ __ ] what I go
you must see Allah I thank you I get it
well I found a chipper he doesn't like
tippers okay [ __ ] you [ __ ] down
[Applause]
tipper I got a ship I already got two
the luxans Eldon Wyck Oh No okay Kiki
Kiki [ __ ] this [ __ ]
not funny not funny not funny not funny
not funny not funny
come on guys that bet
[Applause]
- [ __ ] she doesn't even know how to bow
I'm outta here I'm out here bow there's
that back alright let's go in here
[ __ ] ladder nerd and I'm like a boss
what does it say needs hunter
but my life but my life but my light saw
something here Oh
Patel is that what if I tell you with my
life stop chasing me I don't have any
live in either no I don't have [ __ ] I
neither sell just kill myself oh yeah
please
I still out there is me that little
[ __ ] I need to find something to seal
no reason what you know make a girl do
so much you can say how am I still alive
I'm a [ __ ] he-man ah
[ __ ] my life
oh hello little he's out of [ __ ]
people
[Laughter]
I mean after leaving I don't even [ __ ]
word up after living room after living
room
all right forget very good for now I
can't do this [ __ ] anymore where it's so
dark come on come on brow jammer pity
Pass he likes to read Twilight but it
doesn't hear me you show him pity I'm it
[Music]
anyway
it's gotta come bro - then I'll see you
next episode I'll write Tara
[Music]
that's how I roll
wait you're a fanatic what did I tell
you booth we don't rape people